what on Earth happened
and then
everything changed
no I I can't bear the thought of it I
think it I cringe when I think about it
um
I mean when they got married I was so
thrilled I felt like it was a new era
and now I'm just so embarrassed and
I just wish those two brothers would be
friends again I mean it's all about
family isn't it I just it all feels
quite staged and I'm sure there has been
a lot that's gone wrong but there is in
every family and you just shut up and
Talk Amongst yourselves you don't air it
to the world
I think it's about time that the Royals
have actually got a voice to say what
they need to say and get it across to
the people that think everything is
um what's the word I'm looking for
everything is cool and dandy and it's
not so good for them perfect
I I I hope it works out very well for
them I think they've had a bit of a
rough time
um but they've made they've said a few
things in sort of in preparation for it
that are a little bit sort of
bum squeaky they don't really see the
irony
you know Harry's comment about
um
or what was it about hierarchy
he's complaining there's a hierarchy in
the royal family and it's like Han
you're the hierarchy that's there but
yeah I hope it goes well for them gossip
behind the scenes I like to know kind of
how they're feeling what's been
happening I heard there's going to be a
lot of a lot of kind of little secrets
and tales coming out so I'll be looking
forward to that
um I mean I'll probably watch it because
we all watch them right they come in
they get fashionable what's not to love
but I don't know I guess it's kind of
it's an institution in the UK right so I
don't know they're welcome to do
whatever they want to do but I'm not
really sure it's the right time for them
to do it but you know let them live
their lives
tabloid news
Megan I think they're brilliant couple I
just feel really sad about what's
happened from them being this sort of
power couple to sort of plummet in to
all this sort of nonsense that I see of
racism and you know her battling with
her mental health so it'll be
interesting to get a bit more insight to
really what they were experiencing
um I'm still keeping an open mind about
the documentary because there's always
two sides to a story but I just do think
it's it's fair that they're telling
their version and speaking their Truth
for Harry to do what you've done with
his wife I don't get in wrong for taking
her out because I think eventually it
would have come around to not the same
kind of thing but she would have
suffered
has been a mixed race lady
in a rural family from America as an
actress come on
they wanted to leave the royal family
for lack of privacy which I can
understand I agree with them I wouldn't
want that lifestyle but then to to you
know to have this Netflix and to I feel
they're just doing it for money and so
no I I don't agree with them
I think at the moment I think Harry
needs to men Broken Bridges with his
family
there's an awful lot going on between
the family and with Charles being King
shortly I think there needs to be a bit
more
communication and hopefully that Harry
will come over and do a little bit more
for the Royal Family
[Music]